fencing off the capitol
and millie
from the moment he decided to run for
president biden's been eager to convince
you
that he's an above board kind of guy
the vice president harris and i and our
entire administration will always be
honest and transparent with you about
both the good news and the bad but i
will always be honest with you
about both the progress we're making and
what setbacks we meet we just have to
keep telling the truth well those were
just words and now we know they were
totally meaningless
eight and a half months into his
presidency we see that right now joe
biden's running the government on a need
to know basis and the less you know
the better for him
now take the deteriorating situation at
our southern border a few months back
the biden administration banned
reporters from visiting migrant
detention facilities so much for
transparency the overcrowding the
horrific conditions the unaccompanied
minors they didn't want you to see any
of it
and yesterday biden's faa swooped in to
impose temporary flight restrictions
over the international bridge at the
border in del rio texas and it was only
after pressure from fox was the decision
rescinded
you see they don't want you to see the
crush of 12 000 plus migrants that want
to enter our country at the border
of course though it's not just the
denials and cover-ups limited to the
border crisis general mark milley just
admitted to the ap that he did in fact
call his pla counterpart
but he claimed it was perfectly within
his duties notice he avoided saying it
was a perfect phone call
that millie thinks it's fine for
military leaders to coordinate and warn
our most serious foreign adversary is
yet another reason the general should be
terminated immediately
he's totally delusional or drunk on his
own power and he should not be trusted
with any sensitive information or
operational details
now last night if you saw but senator
john kennedy told the angle audience
that he thought millie wouldn't survive
this controversy that biden would have
to throw him under the bus
maybe i'm maybe i'm wrong i disagree
with them but i just don't see it
because the dems response to every
mistake every accusation every scandal
is to dig in deny deflect and defend i
see nothing
in what i've read
that would
that would cause any concern the
president has complete confidence in his
leadership his patriotism and his
fidelity to our constitution
oh yeah typical cliche written defense
well
where the transcripts of these phone
calls have been going on apparently for
five years where the notes are members
of the press corps suddenly in curious
these were secret negotiations and as we
know china has the transcripts so they
know exactly what was said but
the american people i think are going to
be kept in the dark
the truth is the independent media in
the united states is dead it no longer
exists
we should just call them the regime
media going forward i think i will
and the biden transparency and
truthfulness pledge is officially dead
today the administration finally had to
own up to the fact that its drone strike
that millie referred to as righteous
killed 10 innocent afghans
now i'm convinced the administration was
forced to finally come out and admit
this after that new york times report
and actual videotape of the carnage was
released and of course the international
outcry that followed
millie was involved and they were all
involved in this but they built fences
around millie
they cordoned him off from
accountability
and now
they've rebuilt their fencing around the
capitol and another blatant act of
security theater because supposedly
there's a rally that they admit will
only attract 700 people
it's not a rally that president trump is
attending or urging others to attend by
the way but that doesn't matter the
biden people and the hill democrats are
using it as a pretext to dredge up more
insurrection talk we are predominantly
consumers of intelligence
rather than producers
well that is no longer that was prior to
january 6.
we have now grown and expanded our
intelligence operations we have already
transitioned into an enhanced security
posture on capitol grounds as you can
see by the security fence and various
other security measures that are in
place
externally we have been working with
over 25 of our partnering agencies on a
seamless integrated plan for this
weekend the obsession about this rally
the erection of the security perimeter
all the press conferences also has the
added benefit of preventing you the
people from having
access to the capital that you
rightfully deserve you pay for it after
all
more fences means fewer american
citizens get to see how their government
actually works
or doesn't
remember house democrats house members
can still vote from home
remember what i've said from the start
at its heart the bide administration is
basically just one big com shop if they
had good news they'd communicate with
you about it
but the bad news keeps rolling in on
every level and they're working overtime
to keep it from you
and so they're lying to the american
people about the border about what
general milley did about what really
happened in afghanistan and about the
significance of this stupid rally
tomorrow